الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
على ان الجيش الاوكراني اسقاط سبعه صواريخ
كروز روسيه فوق العاصمه خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه وقد شنت القوات الروسيه
هجوما صاروخيا واسعا على معظم مقاطعات
البلاد بما فيها في اقصى الغربه وفيوديسا
الجنوبيه البلاد قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
دفاعاته الجويه تمكنت من اسقاط خمسه عشره
طائره مسيره روسيه من اصل 25 استهدفت
المنطقه واعلن عن مقتل احد العاملين في
موانئ تصدير الحبوب على نهر الدانوب جراء
الهجمات الروسيه المتواصله منذ ثلاثه ايام
هذا ونشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صورا قالت
انها لغارات شنتها مقاتلات حربيه من طراز
25 على مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه وذلك ضمن
العمليه الخاصه شرقيه اوكرانيا على حد
تعبيرها من جانبه قال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه ان الوضع على طول الجبهه
الشرقيه لا يزال صعبا حسب وصفه
من كياف مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقد معنا
ايهاب ارحب بك المزيد من التفاصيل حول
الوضع ليس في العاصمه كيف فقط وانما على
كل الجبهات سواء الشرقيه او الجنوبيه
وايضا غربا على ما يبدو
الفجره هذا اليوم شنت القوات الروسيه
هجوما واسعا النطاق بالصواريخ وبالمسيرات
الصواريخ استهدفت مدينه كييف تحديدا اذ
اطلقت القاذفات الاستراتيجيه عده صواريخ
من نوع كروز ارفق باطلاق صاروخ باليستي من
نوع اسكندر ام على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
القوات الجويه اعلنت انها اسقطت جميع هذه
الصواريخ التي كانت استهدفت العاصمه
الاوكرانيه ياتي استهداف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه في وقت نقلت وسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه عن ان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن سيجري محادثات هذا اليوم مع
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين هنا في العاصمه
كييف وايضا ياتي بالتزامن مع اعلان
الاخفاق عن التوصل الى اتفاق بشان اتفاق
الحبوب الذي كان بحثه الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان مع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين المسيرات الاوكرانيه استهدفت لليوم
الثالث موانئ تصدير الحبوب اذا سقطت خمسه
نحو عشره مسيرات على ميناء اسماعيل في
منطقه اوديسا مما ادى الى مقتل شخص على
الاقل واصابه عدد اخر
والحق في بالمرفا اضرار كما اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه اسقط خمسه عشر مسيره من قبل
الدفاعات الجويه وفق ما اعلنت قياده منطقه
الجنوب كل ذلك ياتي بالتزامن مع استمرار
الهجوم الاوكراني في محاوله لخرق الدفاعات
الروسيه عند الجبهه الجنوبيه وتحديدا في
منطقه القوات الاوكرانيه تتحدث باستمرار
عن ان هجماتها تحقق مكتسبات على الارض دون
ان تحدد طبيعه هذا التقدم لكن الواضح ان
القوات الاوكرانيه باتت تقاتل عند الخط
الدفاعي الثاني
في عدد من النقاط وهي كانت اعلنت اليوم عن
تقدم ما في نقطتين الى القريبه من منطقه
وتحديدا عند التقاء حدود المقاطعتين وايضا
في الشرق تحدثت القوات الاوكرانيه عن ان
الوضع صعب هو معلنه قائد القوات البريه
الذي كان في تلك المنطقه يتفقد قواته
وتحدث عن ان القوات الاوكرانيه تواصل
قتالها في هذه المنطقه في محاوله لصد
الهجمات الروسيه باتجاه منطقه كوبيانس وان
القوات الروسيه تقوم بتدريبات للمزيد من
الهجمات في تلك المنطقه باعتبار ان التقدم
باتجاه تلك الجبهه سيؤدي الى اختلال
موازين كثيره على الارض وستصل القوات
الروسيه الى منطقه حيويه على مستوى
المواصلات الضروريه التي يمكن ان تصل خطوط
سكه القطار ما بين اوكرانيا وروسيا اشكرك
هذا العقد كنت معنا منك